ac lors de notre second débat dans ce
sens public vous le savez il est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour pour prendre du recul ce soir c'est
l'avenir de nos universités qu'on va
scruter le 13 janvier dernier le présent
la république présentait ses ambitions
réformatrices en la matière et une
petite phrase sur le prix de
l'enseignement a ravivé les tensions
autour des frais d'inscription
américaine
l'université française pour est elle un
jour devenir payante le 13 janvier
emmanuel macron avait à demi-mot ouvert
la porte à une possible augmentation des
frais d'inscription pour les étudiants
on ne pourra pas rester durablement dans
un système où l'enseignement supérieur
n'a aucun prix pour la quasi totalité
des étudiants ou un tiers des étudiants
sont considérés comme boursier heo
pourtant nous avons tant de précarité
étudiante et une difficulté à financer
un modèle qui est beaucoup plus financé
sur argent public que partout dans le
monde pour répondre à la compétition
internationale
l'elysée a depuis rétropédaler il
n'empêche ces mots ont fait réagir
vivement les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
il accuse tankers emmanuel macron
d'avoir délaissé l'université publique
pendant le quinquennat parler de la
hausse des frais d'inscription pour les
familles qui sont aujourd'hui en vraies
problématiques de pouvoir d'achat alors
même qu'il ya un désengagement aussi
fort de l'état pour l'université pour
moi c'est la vocation il a décidé
délibérément de
sacrifier l'enseignement supérieur et
l'université c'est le président le plus
jeune de la vème république et c'est le
président le plus anti jeunes de la
cinquième république 110 longs un
rapport de l'institut montaigne un think
tank libéral alerte est en avril dernier
sur le cruel besoin de financement de
l'université en france où le budget
alloué en moyenne par étudiant est en
baisse constante depuis 2010 à
contre-courant des autres pays de l'
ocde et où un étudiant sur cinq quitte
les bancs de la fac sans aucun diplôme
alors face au manque de moyens
l'augmentation des frais d'inscription
est elle une solution à quelques
paradoxes à vouloir répondre au défi la
jeunesse en décidant de deux opposants
que le financement des universités
bascule sur les familles